like Rumble I don't think is
decentralized I just think it's got its
own servers sort of reminds you of Elon
Musk and starlings got its own servers
but it's still owned by that individual
for me personally that concerns me a
little bit because I love Twitter right
now I can say all these amazing things
you can say there's only two genders
because Elon Musk allows that right we
don't know what could happen with Elon
Musk I genuinely believe everybody is
corruptable everybody has a price like I
don't know what could happen to Elon
Musk I mean he won't let Alex Jones back
so I'm often really concerned that these
good actors could potentially become Bad
actors